les amis l'heure est grave voici loin
qui est déjà en train de faire des
conneries avant même que je commence
cette vidéo et tu arrêtes tes bêtises
reste tranquille restant chat c'est bien
mon chat
vous l'avez jamais vu avant ce jour et
c'est normal je voulais prendre les
devants et que vous voyez tout de suite
son vrai visage
une petite pensée pour djabou qui avait
réussi à passer devant vous pour un chat
coup là tu peux intégrer dans ciel as-tu
abîme le siège tu veux je te dirai son
bisou bisou loi est la sainte croix gelé
maintenant depuis près d'un mois et la
presse eut réussi à faire passer pour un
chat mignon il est maintenant temps de
rétablir la vérité petit tu joues avec
ta queue et d'hommes sous le pass te
plaît des traces de griffes de gros fils
de [ __ ] sur mon siège en cuir un max de
plaisir à chaque le vote constamment ma
place un vrai plaisir loi le point
positif c'est que c'est un petit chien
et bien on va monter les conneries tu as
peur mais c'est très bien qu'elle n'a
pas droit de rentrer dans ce récit elle
vous allez voir elle va venir en cours
en loi loi add on pack way you loi rien
de regarder comme des fourmis
elle courait du fibda honte non c'est
non ma petite autre truc extrêmement
bizarre ce chat 1,2 hors de l'eau
ce doigt le fait carrément gens qui
n'aiment pas parce que sa femme est en
train de tourner une vidéo taignonnes
entêté rythme était mignonne quand même
on t'aime bien petit cul à yahoo plus
gros qu attendait son caca ici je
bougeais font caca bien qu'à tahiti qui
a fait caca
64 cas de ouf ben ali a par 5 à 4 aux
c'est ici au sénégal mais non mais
[ __ ] elle met les pattes de dans l
armée sur le miroir
[ __ ] et la chine et non sur le parquet
attend c'est abusé je découvre sache
depuis combien de temps ces l'a amené le
human augmente elle a fait notre gestion
l est du coup y'a trop de tenir et ça
n'excuse rien elle se cacher leur jeu
deux fois je te vois ça ça a tourné
autour de ça je dirais que ça c'est caca
ici est en poche août et parce qu'elle a
vécu
mais va pas du tout cas qu'à mais pas
dans tout match
rip peluche on t'aimait wasquehal ou non
à jumbo mon bébé toi tu chies pas
partout moi toi t'es pas comme ça
de fait elle est utile à l'équipe qui
allait tout le monde et 107 étages est
infecté on met en quarantaine
bon voila c'était loin j'ai oublié de
vous montrer je raccourcis ces deux
options finalement je dois nettoyer ce
qu'on appelle un énorme qu un catcheur
mais je vous jure j'ai encore envie de
vomir savate samaté fier voilà cette
mise en garde je tiens à sauver votre
esprit mais aussi votre parquet préfère
maximum de monde autour de vous les
chats sont en réalité des démos ils ont
déjà envahi internet
ils ont déjà envahi internet quelle sera
donc la prochaine étape et les traits
l'onu peut-être
attention ne sont partout j'ai entendu
en attaque le matin qu'elle veux
m'attaquer
elles vont attaquer laissez-moi les
héros je crois qu'elle est partie